once you figure out how to persuade
now you have to decide what you're going
to do are you going to use your powers
for good or evil you know and Adam when
you start talking about you know a sign
of disrespect it's interesting because
the Zuckerberg shows up in a T-shirt and
this guy shows up in cargo pants and you
know it's it doesn't quite land the same
way except that it did I mean look at
Bill Clinton look at is that that's Tony
Blair right yes I mean former prime
minister of the
two of the most powerful men on the
planet are sitting next to this
sky and they have to decide you know is
he so incredibly comfortable in his own
skin is he so amazingly authentic that
that we're now feeling we're The
Establishment we're we're stodgy we're
we we're fake in our ridiculous suits
and ties this guy's the real deal I
guarantee you a lot of people who
invested in him saw him as authentic and
persuasive precisely because he was
disrespectful in the traditional way and
I just you know I every single day
there's in my life anyway there's a
moment where I have to like think about
that last night I presented
an award at the Patriot Awards and right
up to the last minute I couldn't decide
if I should wear a tie and I never
really agonize over this stuff too much
but some people are in tuxedos and then
they're at the next table or the guys
from Duck Dynasty and they got their
beards and their flannel shirts and they
don't give a [ __ ] right they don't care
and then you know it's it's just very
hard to know in this world where where
people have a perception of you
how do you dress and when when do you
stop trying to fit in in that
traditional sense in the end I put a tie
on just because you know I'm I just
thought that was a smart thing to do and
frankly my shirt didn't fit great kind
of bunching up a little bit but the
point is right now it's obvious right
now there's there's nothing authentic
right really there's nothing impressive
here you know but in the moment
with 32 billion dollars behind you sold
the caricature of the mad scientist
correct I'll say one thing real quick
for me this comes down to knowing the
difference between right and wrong so
you use the the coin analogy right and
you can be awkward and you know
authentic and I'm just keeping it real
and I'm showing up with shorts and cargo
shorts and with the sitting with a
former president United States and
former prime minister okay cool but
there's a track record here okay the
look The Hair the shorts to me
disrespectful not reading the room not
just you know showing showing class all
right what he's accused of is
commingling funds right and taking money
from Alameda capital
and using it to fund FTX and whatever
that was that was clearly wrong called
fraud fraud okay thank you the dating of
the CEO and you know that whole thing
and whether that was appropriate or not
you know this is that's why I asked you
sort of the the uh on the Spectrum thing
the the thing you hear about the
spectrum is that you're not taking
social cues and you're just sort of
disregarding social norms and their
traditions and norms for a reason right
and it just seems to me that you know he
was hiding under the guise if I'm the
smartest guy in the room trust me all
this bitty Bops crypto and blockchain
like just trust me I'm smarter than all
of you but behind the scenes it's kind
of almost like behind the curtain The
Wizard of Oz or the emperor has no
clothes on it turns out that he was
actually just a fraudster and just
completely being disrespectful here
here's what else is missing right I
don't know exactly what that event was
but if those two guys were there then
there were lot of other people there
there was a lot of security there there
was a lot of money there right every
everything was there except somebody
in charge who had the balls to say sam
not in that outfit right okay it's
called a dress code right and we don't
care what you've done or who you are but
it just it's as simple as a dress code
you know there there many many many many
many many restaurants that you wouldn't
be allowed to walk into dressed like
that you really think you're going to
sit down here with two of the most
powerful men on the planet you know
looking like a skater
no you know and guess what we just
Googled you and it seems you can afford
a jacket and tie go get one right there
was no one there to say it because
saying that would have been about the
most uncool thing in the world so that
guy doesn't have he's not subjected to
dress codes he's not subjected to what
you said Tom we're gonna find out if the
rules apply to Ms Holmes all right the
rules don't apply to him not yet they're
about to toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign